[Musica]
ecco quello lì il mio nome
quindi tutti quanti voi pensate che
quello sia il mio vero nome
in realtà io anagraficamente non mi
chiamo noi anni io mi chiamo al da
marina via coi anni
a quanti di voi non piace il proprio
nome
ecco nemmeno a me piaceva il mio nome un
po per la lunghezza insomma al da
marinai aquilani lunghissimo in più
faccio un po parte di quella categoria
degli italiani a cui viene dato il nome
del proprio nonno nonna
ecco è successo anche a me un po quelle
usanze del sud
mio padre infatti ha origini del sud e
alda era il nome di mia nonna ecco a me
questo nome non mi è mai piaciuto un po
per il suono
ho scoperto anche che ci sono 28 mila
alte in italia
un po perché probabilmente legavo questo
nome a quello che è stata un po la mia
infanzia
la mia adolescenza che non è andata
esattamente come avrei voluto
quindi legavo questo nome a tutto che
era era stato tutto il mio percorso
tutto il mio trascorso che all'età di
circa 20 anni mi sono resa conto che
proprio non mi piaceva il nome
ovviamente è stato l'apice di tutto
questo mi ricordo un evento
mi ricordo che andai a cercare un
risvolto positivo inerente al mio nome
andando a cercare il significato un po
quelle cose che facciamo un po lo so
forse un po tutti quello di cercare una
cosa bella
un doppio significato quindi con tutto
l'entusiasmo del mondo dai su google
digita il mio nome per sapere il
significato quindi alga significato nome
uguale
vecchio
cosa avrei dovuto fare
diciamo che ero un po presa male un po
da tutto quindi
ero veramente molto abbattuta anche dopo
questa notizia
quindi
diciamo che ho realizzato che io ho
sempre avuto un grande sogno nel
cassetto quello di fare qualcosa
attraverso l'arte io sento un bisogno
comunicativo nell'arte
non importa in quale forma io sono
attratta da tutte le forme artistiche e
mi rendevo conto che nel piccolo paesino
dove sono cresciuta perché io sono di
montecatini terme che da un paesino con
comunque una mentalità un po particolare
un po chiusa non mi sentivo compresa non
sentivo che niente e nessuno
potesse darmi la possibilità di
comunicare qualcosa
quindi ho fatto un po quello che
molti di noi pensano sia meglio perché
nel nostro immaginario
gli altri fanno sempre meglio di noi gli
altri paesi soprattutto stanno meglio di
noi quindi
aggrappandomi un po questo american
dream sono adattata a mia madre e io ho
detto mamma io me ne vado si lascia
tutto mi trasferisco a new york 9 mila
chilometri di distanza da te mia madre
non come tutte le madri non è che è
stata così molto felice di questa
notizia nonostante sia una persona molto
aperta
mi ha supplicato nel tuo ti prego almeno
compra il biglietto di ritorno con una
data
mobile insomma che tu possa tornare da
un momento all'altro se tu dovessi
trovarti male lì visto che insomma sarai
da sola non parli inglese
assolutamente no gli ho risposto io
andrò lì e lì sarà al mio posto perché
lì sono sicura che mi comprenderanno con
8 milioni di persone sono a manhattan
qualcuno ci sarà che mi darà la
possibilità di fare qualcosa perché io
dove sono nessuno mi capisce non c'è
niente di bello dove abito e così ho
fatto le valigie e leo riempite di sogni
e ho lasciato al da casa e quando mi
sono sono atterrata a new york
sono è diventata un'altra persona si
perché mi sono chiamata no
no era il nome che voleva darmi una
madre e di cui ci sono particolarmente
affezionata per questo motivo è un po
anche per non recare danno ai miei
genitori perché comunque non è bello
dire a un figlio che rinnega diciamo il
proprio nome mi è stato dato dei miei
genitori un po ho detto vabbè io da
domani mi trasferisco in un altro paese
e diventa una persona nuova quindi
immaginatevi che da domani
voi vi presentiate con il nome che vi
piace di più
così e io ho fatto ho fatto esattamente
questo è così arrivato a new york
inevitabilmente ho iniziato a cercare
lavoro quindi con il mio portfolio in
mano il portfolio è la raccolta di tutte
le immagini quindi avevo raccolto un po
di immagini di quello che facevo ho
iniziato a girare di studi e
entravo in minuti in tutti gli studi di
new york perché dovete sapere che
appunto come mi ha detto il presentatore
io sono una tatuatrice ho cercato lavoro
come tatuatrice e
in tutti gli studi si
si
succedeva sempre la stessa identica cosa
il proprietario
io li mostrava il mio lavoro lo guardava
sfogliava
annuiva poi mi riguardava
chiudeva il mio portfolio melo ridava e
mi dice maghazi ma non siamo interessati
ma io non capivo quale fosse il problema
eppure il mio lavoro era comunque valido
non era artisticamente complesso erano
tali apposta datemi la possibilità di
fare qualcosa eppure in tutti gli studi
è successa la stessa identica cosa
è un po iniziamo un po a capire che
forse c'era qualcosa che non andava ma
non capivo esattamente cosa fosse quando
poi ho trovato un piccolo posto che mi
ha preso lavorare non c'era moltissimo
lavoro
in questo posto mi spiegarono quale fu
effettivamente il problema mi dissero ma
nessuno ti prendo a lavorare se tu non
hai parte del corpo tatuato
i modi ma come pure importa il mio
lavoro di come io lo faccio
e invece no io ho rotto uno schermo
perché io non avevo neanche un tatuaggio
è a new york era molto caldo perché io
sono arrivata il 26 di giugno e quindi
andando in canottiera avevo le braccia
scoperte e i proprietari degli studi
nomi volevano perché io non facevo parte
della categoria dei tatuatori veri
perché a quanto pare non importa quanto
tu sia bravo importa intanto avere buona
parte del corpo tatuato perché non basta
avere qualche tatuaggio sparso
eh si io ho rotto gli schemi
in realtà anche tuttora perché io anche
oggi non ho neanche un tatuaggio
eppure continua a fare questo lavoro
mentre ero a new york
new york è una città meravigliosa non so
se ci siete mai stati una città che ti
offre veramente
qualsiasi cosa a new york tutto è
possibile è pieno di eventi è pieno di
cose da vedere piano di di tutto ti
riempie e quindi a paragone di
montecatini terme proprio non c'era
voglio dire avevo tutto il mondo a
disposizione
eppure eppure più andava avanti in più
le cose
non erano esattamente così come avrei
pensato perché new york è una città
molto difficile
mi ricordo che per arrivare alla fine
del mese arrancava economicamente perché
è una città veramente molto cara
e con il lavoro mi dice mi dissero
guarda preparati perché frame pone
dovrai fare un altro perché durante
l'inverno non ce la farei a mantenerti
previsti ma come cavolo
eppure il mio lavoro insomma
è valido quindi dovrei lavorare di più
e invece le cose andavano così e in quel
momento
mi ricordai di un evento che era
accaduto esattamente l'anno prima di new
york cioè io ci provai sempre stessa
retorica a londra parti per una
settimana cercando lavoro a londra
perché io ero convinta ero convinta che
questo che quello non fosse il mio posto
io dovevo andare fuori e quindi andare a
londra in uno studio di cui il
proprietario italiano per fortuna quindi
capito perfettamente
e fece più o meno la stessa cosa quella
di guardare mio portfolio
lo chiuse e mi guardò e mi disse ma tu
perché puoi venire a londra e gli
spiegai guarda io dove abito non sono
compresa io non riesco a fare niente non
sono cioè non posso non ho la
possibilità o bisogno di stare in una
grande città dove le persone mi possono
capire e dare la possibilità di fare
qualcosa di diverso io voglio fare lo
stile realistico che era complicato ai
tempi
e lui mi guardò e disse
ma tu filip leu lo conosci
ecco questa sono io con filip leu
qualche anno dopo si vede la mia faccia
felice ecco filip leu dovete sapere che
è stato uno dei più grandi precursori
del mondo del tatuaggio lui ha cambiato
ha rivoluzionato completamente il
tatuaggio giapponese
e io gli risposi a questo proprietario
certo che mi ricordo certo che so a chi
ha filip leu tutti lo sanno ecco allora
mi rispose se sai chi è filip leu sai
anche dove abita
e io mi soffermo a pensare
questi se mi pare sia svizzero
lui mi disse sì è svizzero
infatti ma nessuno sa esattamente
dove abiti perché lui abita in un
piccolissimo paesino sperduto sulle
montagne svizzere
quindi se lui ha fatto quello che ha
fatto lo puoi fare anche tu da dove sei
io ovviamente non gli credette tornai a
casa e l'anno dopo appunto parti per new
york
mentre ero a new york
camminavo andava avanti in quello che
credevo ma c'era qualcosa che mi mancava
ancora non capivo esattamente cosa però
le cose diciamo che le stava maturando
mi mancava qualcosa e ho realizzato
tutto questo quando vi ricordo che
chiamavo le mie amiche
ero al telefono con una delle migliori
amiche ai tempi e le dissi
sai che forse forse mi manca un po a
casa
forse chiamo la compagnia aerea e santo
semi anticipo al volo
forse aveva ragione mia madre
così attacca il telefono chiamai la
compagnia aerea e mi dettero il volo
dopo due giorni in due giorni realizzai
che dove dovrete appunto sganciarmi da
tutte le situazioni che avevo e partire
e tornare a casa
ecco io abitavo all'inizio della freccia
e la fine della freccia è la mia
passeggiata perché sono sci uscì quei
giornalisti vado a fare una passeggiata
e feci 10 chilometri a piedi le feci
tutti piangendo si piangevo le persone
mi guardavano ovviamente new york ma non
mi importava niente perché io piangevo
un po perché ero delusa ma un po ero
molto felice di tornare nella mia
piccola realtà
si è
probabilmente una piccola realtà mi dava
molto di più
tornata a casa
cambiò una cosa fondamentale quello che
i new york mi ha insegnato nonostante
sia stata per me una delle più grandi
delusioni ma il più grande insegnamento
che ho avuto è che quando tornai a casa
iniziai a vedere tutto da un altro punto
di vista
tutto quello che rinnega vaud e che non
mi piaceva era diventato oro ai miei
occhi era tutto i miei amici la mia
famiglia le mie piccolissime cose sono
diventate enormi e da allora
ho aperto tre studi dica tu ag adesso il
quarto e ho girato tutto il mondo pur
avendo la mia base né piccolissima base
a montecatini terme
e prima della pandemia in realtà mi ha
chiamato a lavorare a new york per come
guest uno dei più grandi studi al mondo
per me è stata una grande
una grande rivincita visto tutte le
porte in faccia e poi ricevuto e oltre a
questo
due anni fa ho partecipato a un concorso
internazionale per una scultura in marmo
perché io mi occupo anche di scultura
sono appunto solo una scultrice artista
e questo concorso per l'aeroporto di
fiumicino
io l'ho vinto ha vinto il premio
e sapete che cosa mi hanno chiesto a
fiumicino o meno diritto ma come la
firmiamo la tua opera
e io gli ho risposto la firmiamo al da
marinai a coi anni sì perché
non importa ho capito questo che non
importa né come ci si chiami è né dove
ci si trovi importa esclusivamente
quello che si è
[Applauso]